tre
あああああああああああれた
[音楽]
はぁっはいということでパタパタバードでございます特に深い意味はないですよ店で
見つけてのがその飛ぶ鳥みたいのがあったんで買っちゃいましたベンチが不要でと
ブラシでこういうトリガー入ってます
本物の鳥のように飛びますって書いております何とかにバード正直全然期待してない
ですただ乗った区で商品カートばないこういうだったんだなと思う
開けてみましょう頭の右脇についている
[ __ ]鉄レーサーキロは帰宅なうわーーー
て
うんでこれねーもんなんですエヴァええなあああ
うん
詰まってなきゃでそんなわけないだろうちょっと中でもやらなきゃいけないんだ
ちょっとやることじゃないと飛ばないっぽい進まず頭が宮城でついてレバーを上にあげ
ますということをちっぽの下についている
ハントので10分ほど申します
を
であっはぁなんとなくわかった
ではを上げてセットす状態デー回っ
ぞってレバー話ぞ
[音楽]
ん
ああそういうことかそれまでチャージするんですよ
噂だチャージして
re
なんとどうだったの実際に富む所に仙台市を選ばれた
てい
4日
th
はあああこんなちょっ w
間違いまだ違うし
ます
[音楽]
おーすげー
うわぁぞ
いいしています
ています
5とってもいい感じの商品でしたね
ブーブー you do
ます
見たいんですねはいです
が見えてながらだ今